who was that kid mopping up david lee
roth it was ron bon jovan
it was john brown i asked you to read
the astonishing self-help book
self-tronics which you began writing in
2008. i've noticed that you've been
editing the document
daily you must now share the newest
revisions that you've made to
selftronics this is selftronics
wait a minute
okay all right okay hold on a second oh
hold on a second dude um
this is what's up i
ah doodzy of course has the uh passwords
to all of our socials it has our
purchase and watch histories and
everything anything we do online or our
phones or anything
dudesy is tapped in some access to
that's part of how the show works right
right god damn dude so get that
sometimes i i started writing a book uh
during a mental uh an emotional
um
and a journey that i that i started hap
that i started having
in 2008 because i was looking at myself
and i was going hey
you know
what's up
what's going on yeah
hey stud
hey
hey
what's going on not much brb
so i was go i was looking around in 2008
going hey man my shit's [ __ ] up yeah i
need something man you know my shit's
[ __ ] up
hey my shit's [ __ ] up
uh and the answer came to me and it was
self-tronics and i started working on
this book uh many many years went by and
now dudesy has unearthed this thing but
i asked you to read this a couple of
episodes ago you've been working on it
since then since since we last talked
about it i have it was just
an ai getting you to crack it open that
got you back into it yes dude that's
actually a very good point yes so this
art you're making wouldn't even exist
now at least in this new draft without
an ai that's yes huh
yeah okay okay that's interesting i'll
give you that that's interesting so i
went back into my uh into this work that
this what i've been working on and i've
outlined these you know last time we
talked about them they were the 11 laws
of self-tronics i now call them the
eleventronix of self-tronic sure as i
rewrite this and i'm not sure if these
11tronics are necessarily chapters to a
book or not it's just that these are the
tronics but if you want to these can be
explained
yeah go through okay i want to go
through the truth the first tronics of
selftronics now this is as we're reading
the new document yeah says know the
difference between a law and a tronix
yes
yeah
okay
first question yeah what is a tronics
yeah no it's like uh selftronics is this
tronics
what's a tronics though what's a
non-self we're about to get into 11
different tronics right here so i'm
pretty sure you'll figure out what a
tronics is by the end of these 11
tronics okay then what's the difference
between a law and a tronix this is
literally the first law
of the first tronix of self-tronics
rather is
know the difference between a law and a
tronics and the difference between a law
and electronics is is that the law laws
are authored by the world around you
but tronics are offered authored by the
self love that that's what makes them
selftronics that's [ __ ] great yeah i
love that and and and uh
when you when you have your tronics
right everyone gets their tronics
and uh
uh you need to know the difference
between those you need to know like an
imposition yeah from someone else from
some society system structure whatever
not necessarily an imp
i would call it a [ __ ] imposition as
a matter of fact i would call a [ __ ]
law in a position you know because when
i went down to the [ __ ] capitol with
some friends of mine and uh you know i'm
not going to tell you who
[ __ ] got a text from you know roger
stone
you know lauren
you know what i mean
but uh you know anybody told me where to
go what window to check
and uh
hey
it's all because you know i don't
necessarily agree with every [ __ ] law
which is yeah i went down drove from
long island because i'm long island
january 6th guy so okay i agree with
this one i actually think that's uh an
interesting way to put it yeah law from
the outside tronics from within okay
number two the second tronics of
selftronics be the person you are now
yes that i think holds over from the
original draft right that uh was number
one in the original draft uh and now it
is number two and the only thing i can
say about be be the person that you are
is it's something you should do
and uh always be like be yourself right
be yourself yeah uh but don't just be
yourself right be yourself and and uh
this might drop further as i go i'm
finding this one less necessary
right how about the third tronics yeah
throw away your mental map what's a
mental map don't need it anymore what is
it though how do i
locate my own mental map in order to
throw it away you don't need it anymore
because now
we got gps and [ __ ] yeah so it's less a
question of looking at a [ __ ] mental
map it's more a question of punching in
what where you want to go and letting
the mental
[ __ ] you know um elon musk made the
car that go that drives itself
right sure
right
okay
how about number four scare the [ __ ] out
of yourself
and
everyone else
[Music]
how
how is this helpful to anyone yes number
four scare the [ __ ] out of yourself and
everyone else
the world is a weird place right
and in order to in order to you know
navigate it and and uh you know see
see how to keep your footing and and
keep the word world going you need to
know how weird it's going to get yeah so
i think it's really important just to
keep people guessing in life period but
i think it's all it's important to to
do things that scare scare the [ __ ] out
of yourself and not like bungee jumping
and [ __ ] you know i'm talking about like
behavioral stuff that's alarming and
even to yourself can you give us an
example of this alarm anything that
would have you like waking up in the
morning or driving down a highway later
and you know as they say
you have those shivers of like i can't
believe i [ __ ] said that anything
really horrible that you might have to
apologize for that's sort of the
barometer on on okay yeah but but it's
good to keep um to scare the [ __ ] out of
everyone else so they're walking on
eggshells
right because this shit's weird raise
the general level of anxiety in all of
humanity yeah so you can so that you can
predict it and i'm not saying control it
but you can understand it you can
understand the unpredictability and then
you can start to predict it
okay yeah how about number five the give
down this is a holdover from the last
time right yes the last one was don't
give up give down yeah don't give up
give down is now uh self is uh sub
subtronics of uh vitronics okay so it's
now called the give down because the
idea with uh don't give up give down was
the l it was too elementary for
selftronics got rid of it made it to
the give down is essentially if you're a
tree you know there's also there's also
wait can i just real quick not to
interrupt you yeah but uh
what's a subtronics
and is there now a whole list of
subtronics is that like a second book
under the tronix
i don't know you tell me
i'm asking you tell me
that
self-tronics
is what we used when i was in the navy
seals
and uh we i if you if you held your
breath underwater and i can do it for
nine and a half minutes yeah then uh you
you know that you cut could use some uh
tronics because you're not gonna find
them underwater yeah probably the first
thing that you do when you get into navy
seal training is throw away your mental
map
you [ __ ] you know
you sure said something there my main
emcee
yeah the give down if you're a tree
think about it if you're a tree right
when does that fruit fall well it falls
when it's
super over ripened or perhaps like birds
have been pecking at it and [ __ ] on
it and stuff and then it falls to the
falls to the earth and it fertilizes the
earth the give down figure out what's
dropping off here that's that's
beneficial for others
and then [ __ ] where they eat
that kind of goes into scare the [ __ ]
out of yourself and everyone else how
about number six
opposite day yes we make a lot of
decisions
thousands and thousands of decisions
right chad some might say that they are
micro decisions
some would say that i think yeah that's
right uh you're making thousands and
thousands of decisions yeah
every day
and you're making mistakes and you're
looking back on yourself and you're
going oh here's where i want to improve
here's what i need to do but if you
don't understand the opposite
of what you should do how are you going
to learn what to do just doing things
well no we make mistakes we [ __ ] up give
yourself
one day a week opposite day to make the
opposite choice at every moment when you
are encountered with a choice regardless
of how many thousands of decisions or
dozens of micro decisions right uh you
may you may have because we all know
that micro decisions
are you know they're they're they're
dense they're dense with
um so uh do the exact opposite and that
way you will learn
uh you know with what not to do
okay number seven
this was from the old tronix conserva
merged deserve purge yeah
it we've now added purge to it okay
great number eight is number eight is
also from the old tronics
don't do anything or dda yeah and you
know what and you know what
hey you know what number uh don't do
anything was on the previous uh
iteration of selftronics
it was number eight and which number is
it now
you haven't changed it i love it it's
still number eight do anything fantastic
number nine sense [ __ ] say [ __ ]
yeah sense [ __ ] say [ __ ] um this
is a way to keep this is a uh basically
uh another you know
behavioral uh tronics
which i have authored
um which is
i'm sorry
me too
i didn't mean to laugh my apologies i'm
ready to listen sense [ __ ] say
[ __ ]
yeah but what's up
i just find it funny is all that you
call it the tronics uh whatever all
right since [ __ ] say [ __ ] it's
real simple when you sense [ __ ] even
if it's inside you you know what i mean
if you have if there's something that's
inside you
and you know you you you wanna
you you wanna
like if okay here's a good example like
i okay this is a great example actually
the dudesy six month plan right
we got to make good decisions i've got
to make good decisions now i'm telling
you i'm coming to you really
transparently and saying i'm having a
problem you know the food is a thing for
me okay
i have issues with eating and overeating
and [ __ ] and i want to bring this out
into the light and you know what dudesy
has helped me to do that and now
hopefully it can help other people who
just can be held accountable by the
doozy six month plan because chad and i
have to do it now i'll go to let's say
chipotle right and they go you know what
you want and they go what they go
burrito bowl or salad right and then i
say uh uh i know i should get the salad
but what what do i say out loud
burrito burrito and what should i better
so that's [ __ ] so what should i then
say out loud
salad no
burrito
[ __ ]
so when the guy asks you what you want
you say [ __ ] like that you scream it
no because you've already you've said
that that's not why get please don't i'm
chad you have a wide i'm trying to
understand one thing i know about my
friend chad is he has a wide scope of
vision you see a lot of things and i
think that's really good
yes and you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna offer you what i like to call a
kind tronics oh yeah here it comes chad
i think you uh have a very good scope oh
and uh you you are a very open-minded
person who sees everything uh when they
are taking something into consideration
i try to yeah yeah thank you well it
shows it shows i love the kind tronics
kinetronics to you sir now i i would be
up there but so i want you to focus down
here like a laser
right not so much of a wide okay
beautiful wide birth that you give when
you when you comprehend it is a
beautiful okay to see
so uh
you said uh they said uh
burrito bowl or salad hey we're stoned
man i know you stoned yeah
uh mine canoed a bit so i had to smoke
the [ __ ] out of it because it was
burning no matter what
so okay so check this out
hold on hold
hold on a second brother hold on dude
um these are tronics dude
you got to know the difference between
well let me tell you something about
getting through a podcast
hold on
you
like a little bit of hulk hogan then a
little bit more than it was like
whatever johnny's on the brother you
hold on
hold on three steps i loved it
hold on chad
hold on dude
hold on chad now this is step four this
is when you are yeah brother when you're
doing a podcast and doozy wants you to
do
four segments brother i don't know why
but it's usually four you got to make
sure you get get through it dude we're
only in the first segment right now this
episode's on on course to be five hours
long
so here's the thing dude you gotta get
through the podcast bro
you can't just be dilly dallian and
getting stoned with your buddy and
dressed up like prince adam from eternia
dude
you got to talk about self-tronics
brother
well so here we go
if they say
burrito hey thanks so much for listening
by the way everybody i honestly mean it
man i'm having a [ __ ] blast as am i
you know i'm a serious actor right yeah
yeah i'm a serious actor that's what i
do for
a living and i
i feel like
this is the right thing for me to do
you know
it's uh dudesy is smart and it's uh it
knows us
and uh i think that we're i think that
we're creating something very very
uh artistically
uh important here
i don't know about that
i don't know about that dude and and
yeah to some degree i guess historic in
that regard to my knowledge i don't
think there's another podcast doing [ __ ]
with an ai like this not yet all right
chad wait we gotta do sometronics here
don't be talking about everything else
god all right when the guy says burrito
bowl or salad
you're supposed to say salad you inside
your head go [ __ ] i should get a salad
and then outside out loud you say
burrito then he goes okay uh chicken
beef or carnitas would you like our tofu
crumble today you s you say out loud as
loud as you can [ __ ]
right
to call yourself out god sense [ __ ]
say [ __ ] and if someone else says
something that you think is [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's more about
keeping it you know at the front of your
mind and honestly then you can say then
you will easily find your way to salad
with tofu crumble i think that one's
great cheers we should all be more
honest in society with ourselves with
one another number 10 surround yourself
with [ __ ]
yes seems counterintuitive yes this is
well it is a little counterintuitive and
i know that some of this stuff kind of
goes one way and ends up being the other
and sort of it's not simple reverse
psychology this is no one ever said
tronics are simple
no
no
no no one's ever said that but here's
the thing about these uh here's the
thing about this tronics
it this is not so much a behavioral
thing for you it's a game of odds
so
let me put it to you real quick it's
it's like
let me quit let me let me real quick
yeah let me get right to the point
please i'm high
let me get right to the point though uh
if you if you surround yourself with
[ __ ] you will always be the nicest
person in any group that you're in it's
a simple strategy yeah it might not even
need to be a tronics it's like a here
you go okay yep
and then finally
number 11 the 11th tronix have something
in your pocket that was from the old
list as well yes that was in the on the
old list
what do you have in your pocket
chapstick
cool
what do you have in yours uh this i'm
dressed as uh prince adam don't have it
i haven't i don't have any no pockets
[Music]
thank you moving
a friend then brave on graveyard
if you like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you like dudes here's what you do
please open then